allein namens luca meine lieben freunde
ich heute wieder recht herzlich
willkommen heißt und seiner neuen
episoden luca reagiert auf zu handeln
die white party
da war mehr stehen geblieben
jetzt meldet sich lana zu wort und die
ist auch ein bisschen dreckig da der
prozess ist fast abgeschlossen okay und
ich möchte eure harte arbeit belohnen
indem ich euch die möglichkeit gebe geld
zurück zu bewahren
bauer
sie können sich ihr geld jetzt
zurückholen was sie verspielt haben oder
wie wir jeden euro müsst ihr 20.000
liegestütze machen
okay wir überlassen was mit dem gerät
allerdings liegt das schicksal der
gruppe in den händen von nur 2
[Musik]
stellt euch vor es ist es irgendwie so
francesca und harry dürfen sich zwei
jahre lang nicht mehr angucken künftige
sluka ihr habt die regeln öfter
gebrochen als alle anderen zusammen
ja die hatten tausende regelverstöße
aber dass wir uns dann jetzt in die hand
von denen die die meisten regelverstöße
hatten gibt es jetzt auch nicht gerade
verlader ja nicht wie schwer es magath
diesen satz auszusprechen er ich spreche
seit 24 jahren muttersprache nicht
deutsch und ich kann die sprache mich
nun habt ihr die chance all das wieder
gutzumachen
dafür müsst ihr eine nacht in der
provinz ried verbringen ich wusste ich
glaube es gibt nicht nur das ich mich
freue wenn francesca und harry irgendwie
was machen müssen
ohne jeglichen körperkontakt ich hab's
geschafft ich es gesagt
die freude ist ja riesig die sache ist
die dürfen halt einfach nicht mit den
anderen leuten in einem raum schlafen
sondern müssen jetzt seine private suite
gehen ohne körperkontakt er ist auch
nicht schwer denn ich habe vertrauen in
die beiden sei
sie sind sauer
ich habe mich extrem weiterbau die sind
nicht neidisch auf eure weiterhin
willkommen
die sind einfach nur abgefragt darüber
dass ihr beiden das ganze geld verspielt
habt und ihr beiden jetzt auch die
einzigen seite die das wieder gutmachen
können
und bei euren intelligenzquotienten sehe
ich da wirklich schwarz wenn ihr den
test besteht wird das preisgeld um die
sommer die harry und francesca bisher
verloren haben aufgestockt
world
also quasi alles als ich meinen die
anderen haben natürlich auch einen oder
zwei mal irgendwie regeln gebrochen aber
hey es kann schon die meiste zeit also
die können wirklich auf einen guten
betrag wieder aufstocken ich habe da
aber wirklich kein vertrauen in die 2
das ist eure chance sich zu beweisen und
sie sagt so was
das kann nichts werden ich nehme jetzt
wetten an fünf euro ist die quote 5 euro
es keine quote 5 euro ist ein geldbetrag
was fällt uns da auf ich hab das wasser
einfach gut zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank gestellt
es ist einfach kalt und eiswürfel die
suite das ist schon fast schon frech
dann legen sie das rosen und so aufs
bett aber ich denke halt wieder ist kann
doch nicht so schwer sein
ihr müsst einfach nebeneinander schlafen
für eine nacht oder sind weil er nochmal
32.000 euro ich werde das richtige tun
so dass lena die uns einfach nicht an
ketten an stuhl
die man nicht irgendwie
der fachmann
die können so viel retten aber die
können noch so viel noch kaputter machen
[Musik]
das macht doch gar keinen sinn
franziska so egozentrischer egoistischer
mensch diese einfache mich
nein von jazz wundervoll
du bist wirklich wundervoll und das ist
klasse und wenn du mal in hamburg
behalten schnauze kleinen pässe 36
stunden auf das entscheidung ein neuer
tag es sieht aus wie eine mischung aus
dem frosch und im krebs es läuft alles
rund
erst diese krebse dann ist sowieso und
leguane aber jetzt mal real talk wir
befinden uns jetzt augenscheinlich bei
dem neuen tag hier
was ist jetzt passiert wer glaubt dass
sie es vergeigt eingelegt wie wir
gelegenheit nach gesprächsthema nummer
eins wir eingelegt die haben es nicht
vergleichen oder wie
so sind in francesco harry könnte jetzt
muss eben gemacht da rauskommen das ist
immer heiß aus und ist jetzt was
passiert oder nicht
was ist das überhaupt so setzt kaffee
oder oder war zwar kommt der her
die müssen ja augenscheinlich zum
catering gegangen sein dort
ja oder ja mal eine kaffeemaschine in
seiner suite es war toll und jetzt
treten wir diesen miesepetrigen nörglern
entgegen ich hab was gegen meine
beziehung und hexer warte mal
damit gibt sie jetzt ja quasi zu dass da
was passiert ist relativ niedrigen
nörgeln gegen ja wenn du das geld von
denen klaus quasi ich liebe dich
trotzdem francesco grandtour hamburg die
zeile 4
wenn man vom teufel spricht da kommt was
ist passiert was passiert man das hier
ist doch so lange herauszögern als ich
reagiere stunde gefühlt viel geld
verloren
natürlich wir sind nicht sicher wie ihr
seid nicht sicher ob ich berührt oder
berührt da gespielt oder wart mal sehen
was leider sagt lada wie wir haben ein
gutes gefühl
die wie ihr habt ein gutes gefühl habt
ihr ein gutes gefühl weil er gestern
nacht eine schöne nacht hatte oder bei
dir die leute nicht betrogen habe die
daneben euch sitzen
mal bin ich richtig in love mit harry
und francesca mit dem kappel so allem
sich und meinte ich bin einfach nur
selbst züchter aufgebot
und taucht unter
aber dieses buch soll bitte kein u-boot
sei carey und francesca haben die
letzten acht in der private suite
verbracht dabei war ihnen jeglicher
körperkontakt untersagt so
gab es den trotzdem
gewiss noch nicht machen sich dann die
ganze zeit für einen ka ihrer mutter hat
sie das mit dem spannungsbogen echt raus
ja warum kann sie es nicht einfach sagen
hat sie bei dem einen schub als und zwar
verschiedene awards in den anderen acht
da sitzt du denn da alter wie
mikadostäbchen das ist doch wirklich
nicht warm an das ist so wie bei
germany's next topmodel ich habe sie
schon alle
[Musik]
heute
kaufen sie jetzt den neuen renault clio
keinen körperkontakt
[Musik]
i
no way
nein da wurden haken dran sein das kann
ich sagen das preisgeld beträgt nun
75.000 dollar hey das wirklich kein
haken dran
die konnten das wieder hoch stockdorf
75.000 dollar da muss man erst mal
klatschen harry und francesca gibt es
hingekriegt eine nacht nebeneinander im
bett zu schlafen ohne euch zu berühren
wahnsinn wirklich meinen vollen respekt